let's hear why you believe aliens are
real we're just a tiny Speck in the big
universe there's no way we're the only
thing out here it's like taking a spoon
taking in the ocean looking at the spoon
being like Oh there's no fish in here
aliens are real man like what have you
seen we're outside I was grilling out
and then we're seeing this thing it's
like a disc but there's no lights in it
all of a sudden a couple seconds later
it's already like above us almost and
we're like
oh shoot go grab your camera this ain't
a plane it wouldn't focus on it but you
could see it clear like clear and then
all of a sudden it was gone like 30
seconds later gone and then I follow
this alien page on Instagram same thing
they said we visited last night by this
UFO it was the same I went crazy are you
sure it just wasn't a regular plane or
nothing no it was too far up there